i was going hard i wanted to go to sleep
every night replying to everybody and
every email
i thought it was imperative i didn't
have a platform other than making real
relationships i believed in it i believe
in it today it's why i'm here right this
second
[Applause]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
so gary first of all thank you for
joining me
and so i want to start this off about a
story
that started in 2011. let's see if it
rings any bells
i had a knicks blog at the time was
writing
every day and was communicating with you
back and forth
and i wanted to go to your book signing
for the thank you economy
back in march of 2011 in new york city
but my mom wouldn't let me go because it
was a school night
and i text you or dm you rather
and i say hey gary my mom won't let me
go to this book signing
you know this is this is the issue i'm
running into and you said
that's great what's her number and you
called her
oh my god brother that's you left her
voicemail
and it is something that my college
friends i talk to
my mom we talk about to this day so what
compelled you
to give your time of day to a 15 year
old kid
and what did you say to my mom to
convince her that
i should come to your book signing i
don't want to lie so i don't remember
all the details of what i said but i
actually remember the setup to this
and i've done maybe like seven to 12
calls in the last 10 years
where i've had enough awareness on me
that people would want such a thing
um a bunch of answers first of all
thanks for having me on the show i mean
you are like winning the serendipity of
my
you completely figured out how to hack
my brain because here's another
serendipitous moment
i also think you did a blog post that i
left a comment to or something like that
right i saw
you say on twitter um so you're clearly
good at getting my attention or saying
what pulls up my heartstrings um
[Music]
you know i think what compels me is
gratitude
you know like i'm grateful like watching
people
resp like me reading the tweets when
i decided to do your podcast randomly
the other night
and people thinking that was cool i'm
not ever gonna be a person who doesn't
think that that's cool
like i'm still the same person in my
brain that i've been
before anybody knew who i was so for me
to think i'm in a place in my life
where people think it's cool that i'm
doing this podcast that like it's a big
thing for you
for me to do this now listen my admin
team my leadership team's mad that i'm
doing this 30
not overall but on december you know
14th we're closing budgets there's a lot
going on right now even i saw it this
morning
because i didn't know i kind of thought
we would do this at night one night late
late night
and i was like ugh you know there's some
real [ __ ] i gotta get
you know but but but that's just
operational that's just valuing time
that's just taking care of your
responsibilities
it's not big timing i'll never be that
person and i'm just humbled by it
and um you know what i probably told
your mom is what i believe
which is if i was doing this right now
for a 15 year i'm like look in my
soul i believe the things that i talk
about and where the world's going and if
you have a 15 year old that's connecting
to it
that this might just actually be a good
use of time because all the things that
you would
do for homework on a school night is
very likely not going to be more
valuable than the people you learn or
some of the ideas that will be put into
your head
at night and so you know i'm sure your
mom appreciated the effort
you know i'm stunned by people's lack of
effort or appreciation
or gr gratitude towards their
communities
it's why i engaged some of the people
that were not as
into me in your comments and saying i'm
sucky or you know
it was really funny i replied to one of
them was like i can't win either i'm
pushing people to not sleep and work too
hard
or pushing people to be too patient and
not go about getting that money
and i was laughing i'm like it's an
unwinnable game and i think context is
everything
um but but the reason i engaged in some
of those comments danny is is because i
appreciate them having opinions like
you know like i know that nobody really
knows me
right you don't you don't really know
you know people that are closest to you
know and like
people are making perceptions and like
the world's crazy people make up [ __ ]
like man
people taking photos with me at the
airport
and then posted on linkedin that we had
a business meeting people
people have said not nice things about
me in public or
private because i didn't give them money
for their startup
and they just make up stuff like life's
complicated and so
you as you start getting more notoriety
and you get more cheering and booing
you kind of got to go into this zen
place of like hey i'm gonna try to do
all the best right things and at the end
of the day
when i'm old and i die more people cheer
than boo
because only so many people are willing
to make up [ __ ] and so
that's kind of how i navigate it's a
beautiful place to be and from what i've
seen
looking at you for the past 11 years is
that same
guy i started following your content
when i was 13 years old
and something in me saw that this person
is gratitude this person
is looking out for the best in people
and it was that that attracted me to you
and to your content
and for that i'm really grateful so my
question to you my follow-up is
what do you do what do you go to that
place when you see all those negative
comments
what is what is going through your head
how are you navigating that
into uh into a positive into empathy
what's practically going on in your head
you know one it's a it's a blend of a
couple things hey
maybe they caught something i said first
first it's accountability
hey maybe i didn't do a good job
explaining something on a podcast
and it turned that person off hey maybe
we didn't edit
an instagram clip well enough and the
context was lost even though i write the
copy always to like
set up the video maybe they didn't read
the copy
um maybe i fired their best friend
and they thought i was unfair because
their best friend didn't tell them the
whole picture
maybe you know i go through those series
of things or me and then i go into the
macro maybe they're unhappy
and you know they just want to tear
somebody down today and
i just happened to be in the feed that
day maybe
maybe they took my advice of being
patient and it was too patient
and they lost and they're like [ __ ]
garyvee and they don't want the
accountability it's more fun to point
point the fingers so for me first i
focus on pointing my thumb at myself
what have i done
to make people misunderstand or maybe
misconstrue
you know when everybody tries to say
that i talk about out overworking
yourself and
hustle porn i'm like man i didn't do a
good enough job in my early career to
talk about
this was contextual to the time you know
the economy collapsed
people were out of jobs people were
hurting the internet was exploding was a
huge opportunity and
even though i talked about being happy
and doing it
for 50 000 a year if it makes you happy
for some reason
maybe my jersey energy maybe because i
didn't do a good enough job clarifying
along the way
maybe i let that word hustle get too
attached
to me and didn't and didn't quite you
know i still love hustle it's called
work ethic
nobody's gonna [ __ ] do anything
without work ethic it's not gonna happen
in a meaningful way but but i don't that
doesn't mean i'm talking about burnout
or suicide or unhappiness as a matter of
fact the reason i think i talk about so
much of not doing it for the cars
and the and the rides and the and the
jewelry and the trips
is because i think that usually means
people want affirmation from others that
they've made it
and that if you care about other
people's opinions that way you become
very vulnerable and i don't want that
for people
because that's what leads to unhappiness
because there's always gonna be somebody
richer more famous
prettier bigger car you know what i mean
you get into this cycle so
you know i by the way the other place i
call my friend i don't expect everybody
to consume 19 hours of my content and
have every tea and i crossed
you know there's a reason that people
that have more consumption of my content
feel better about it because they've
been able to see it contextualize versus
somebody seeing three viral videos ever
and deciding that's who i am so what
goes through my mind is
they're right because they're a human
being and that's their opinion
and i've got to do a better job
clarifying i didn't talk about the fact
in the first 10 years of my career that
my dad owned wine library and i didn't
because i felt like to be frank to be
very transparent
i felt like man i really built a huge
business for my dad and i left and i
didn't want people to be
think my dad was a bad guy you know i
knew that a lot of americans don't know
about immigrant family businesses where
you know like i didn't want my dad to
look bad that i built something for four
to sixty million dollars and i got
nothing woe was me oh my god sasha's
such a dick [ __ ] child labor
you'd [ __ ] you know i didn't want that
so i over protected him
but then that led to people being like
don't listen to this guy who's handed
everything i'm like
[ __ ] that i'm the reverse i gave up the
first 15 years of my career to build
something for
my dad but still someone else and i had
to start vaynermedia in a [ __ ]
conference room because i know [ __ ]
money
so like you know like you know that [ __ ]
something a lot of people don't know
about you is that you were ahead of the
game on domain names
and i believe you owned kanyewest.com at
one point
and gave it away to him for free i gave
it away to somebody
who at the label we had kanye west i
think kanye west was
tv and that's when video was blowing up
we definitely had a young
we had rickross.com we had youngjock.com
yeah we had a bunch you know i was
always playing
you know we owned camus wine and silver
oak and opus one i did that
all the rap stuff in 09 was just because
me aj and mike boyd were into it
and just super hyped on it it was but i
did that in 96 with all the wineries
um and and i didn't do it at a militian
you know i did it out of like you know
i'm gonna grab them because they're an
asset
and then um i um then all those wineries
and all those rappers when i came around
asked for it i was all about that life
it was more all you know
now i i was learning i was trying to
learn
you know like yeah but i loved i owned a
bunch of domain names
you know i owned a lot of cannabis urls
back in the 90s because i was like i'm
going to be in the wine business and
in 20 years cannabis is going to be
legalized and
you know i did i did a great job and
then i did a terrible job because i just
let them run out because
somewhere around year six or seven i was
like oh this is never gonna happen sure
enough it's happened
um but um yeah i've always liked
understanding consumer behavior what
humans would do and what would be the
assets in that game
and you gave those away or you sold them
how did i gave them away
because because that was really their ip
i was i was hacking having fun but
i would never take a url even the
wineries that are businesses
i gave it to them didn't even you would
feel a little bit better maybe with a
business than with but
it just never it never even crossed my
mind i was gonna take somebody else's
name
i was trying to learn i was trying to
see if i could at the time because
i mean the wine stuff i didn't even you
know people were saying the internet was
a fad so you didn't even know
so at that point i was trying to learn
build other things because i didn't
i wanted to learn how traffic was
working how how search engines work this
is a long time ago
you know with the rap stuff we were
sending we
were sending traffic from myspace
to these sites to then drive back to
their
myspace and other um at the time i don't
think it was
i don't think it was napster it was
learning
it was co that was culture branding you
know
so no i didn't sell any of those because
i didn't think that was the appropriate
thing to do i think it was more about
um about learning what was contemporary
in the market and how traffic worked
around it so it was more like a lab
for me than like a domain squatting
arbitrage and i'm not even sure you know
i'm not
it was never a big game for me so i
don't even know like can you do that to
humans
do you do that with general terms what
the ip laws are trademarks
it just that's not where i go for
money-making um
but it is where i go for learning how
culture works which is something i spend
way more time on than i think
many realize you've said before that
you are going to be the most famous
person in the world
you said that very recently and i'm
curious you said the reason why
is because you know what to do with the
fame and you know
to give kindness and love etc etc but
i'm curious
when did that realization occur to you
oh oh [ __ ] we're on to something here
a couple things one i'm just thinking
about like how that statement lands
this will go back to like reasons why
people leave funny comments on social
you know i'm fascinated by how
replicatable
and obvious it is for me to build
awareness for a human or a brand
that was the point if i'm gonna be the
you know that was the context of that
statement
you know i was 34 years old before i
decided to make any real
31 for wine library tv and 34 for
business content
in that it never crossed my mind that
people would know who i was i always
wanted to be a good businessman i always
knew i was a marketer um but
probably about five years ago i was like
wait a minute this is real
probably when i rebooted garyvee
aggressively
you know there's the kind of 2009 to 11
version
13 and 14 i'm pretty quiet except for
keynotes because i'm really deep
in vayner and then when i knew i wanted
to be a prat you know
i checked this out i'm doing it in 2006
to 2011.
vaynermedia is now rolling and i'm
focused in 13 and 14
being ceo but that means i stopped
really doing garyvee content because i
stopped doing wine library tv
in 2011 and i didn't have a daily show i
didn't have anything
somewhere around 2000 early 14 i'm like
wait a minute
what made me dominant was that i was a
practitioner i'm doing it
i'm now two years removed i don't feel
super strong i kind of i
i kind of know how to do facebook
advertising i kind of like
i'm good but i'm not the best in the
world like i was in 2010
or at least one of them you know isn't
me talking to myself by the way
um so rebooting garyvee
was a way for me to with the askgaryvee
show which was the really the start of
this all
and then that led to dailyvee and that
led to being very serious about
instagram and other platforms
that was more about me being a
practitioner
than it was about my notoriety fame
awareness is a byproduct of my obsession
to be a practitioner and the only thing
i have 100
000 control over is me the human being
more than wine library
more than vaynermedia more than anything
i'm involved in
and and that is why i am who i am and do
what i do in my life
you've said that you were one percent
unhappy when you started
wine library i'm curious what were you
one percent
unhappy about my library when i left
when i started wine library tv
yes my dad and i were fighting
really yeah my dad and i were fighting
because
i had built a huge business i was now
30.
you know that 3-0 can even you know i
always talk about don't let 3-0 [ __ ] you
up but like
it's because i even for me i have to
question myself like hey
november of of 2005 is when i decided
to do wine library tv because i was
checked i was looking at youtube i'm
like this is going to happen
and i was so right about things with
google adwords and email and i was
starting it
different i was starting to change i was
like i'm good at this
i this is different than just being a
wine retailer i
understand communication and i don't
even think i said it that smartly
or to use that big of a word not that
communication is a big word it was just
like
i understand what people are doing or
will i think youtube is going to be big
i'm going to start a youtube show um
but that was really on the back of my
there's a flickr photo
that run that's on the internet and it's
a it's a
bowl of pasta i ate at my desk at wine
library in december of 2005
and it's a drawing a layout of gourmet
library.com i don't say that's what it
is
but it's a drawing of gourmet
library.com
and a yellow bowl with some pasta sauce
i got to find this photo
somewhere on flickr so i have like four
flicker photos
uh and and i basically say
something like one day people will know
why this picture matters
wow and what the picture represented was
i was ready to do something else
but i knew that if i left my dad's
business
and my dad and i were fighting because i
was like starting to feel tension of not
making a lot of money and not owning
anything
and working 15 hours a day for eight
straight years and built a massive
business for him
and he was feeling tension because the
whole industry looked at me as the man
because i was operating
and could care less about him and he
didn't feel like he was being respected
wow so we were both losing which leads
to rams butting heads right
and so i i realized like we were
starting to get close to time where i
always kind of knew
in my back of my mind that i would do
something for myself
potentially if depending on life worked
out
so that's what was happening there and
you know five six seven weeks later i
i filmed the first episode of wine
library tv
uh i was going to launch gourmet library
but my library tv worked
intuitively right away the first 100
episodes nobody gave a [ __ ] but i was
seeing it
and i also was starting to use twitter
right i tried to sign up for twitter
that february that same time
i went to a conference in london the
wi-fi
winked out and i didn't actually create
my account so that may
so funny how life works i was going to
start that february i came back
busy with other things obviously it
wasn't a top priority but by that may
i got onto twitter may of 07. and
between twitter
the work i was doing on twitter driving
to wine library tv
on youtube and viddler and my vlog
which you know back then you embedded
your videos
on a wordpress because you would host
your show on your platform not just
natively on youtube and it was just
happening
and i never got around to gourmet
library it just
you know wine library tv took off drove
my dad's business even more
i was learning i got into web 2.0 i
invested in facebook twitter and tumblr
i started meeting
kevin rose and mark zuckerberg and all
these david carp and all these
interesting people
the early internet youtube buys youtube
sells to google for 1.6 billion i'm like
oh my god this is the world this is the
future
and i dove in headfirst and a couple
years later
vaynermedia comes out and crush it is
written and
my career takes a different turn how
let's fast forward a little bit to when
you
start to blow up let's say on the
internet how do you start to deal with
the fact that you cannot respond to
everybody
because like i was starting to
understand when i was going through
you you blew me up from this this
interview
it's like there's so many comments how
do you deal with the fact
emotionally as such a empathetic person
wanting to help everyone
how do you deal with the fact that you
can't respond to everyone at a certain
point
how do you deal with that emotionally
and mentally it was a tough struggle
as you know that was a big platform i
sat on thank you economy was about
replying to everybody
i did it for five years i used to go to
sleep at four o'clock in the morning
i would wake up at 10 and get my six but
like
i was going hard i wanted to go to sleep
every night replying to everybody and
every email
i thought it was imperative i didn't
have a platform other than making real
relationships i believed in it i believe
in it today
it's why i'm here right this second you
know like
so at some point i knew the math was too
much
and it wasn't for me it wasn't that i
was burning out and i do think that's
what it is for others and
if you feel like you don't like it
anymore you shouldn't but for me it was
i was just growing too fast and like i'm
logical and i was like oh
i could do this for another year but
like the math is very clear
and maybe it's time i get to reconcile
that i can't reply to everybody
and uh but i but i still believe that
replying to everybody on
twitter from mayo seven to let's call it
i don't know where in 2011 i
kind of stopped doing it that was a
weird transition to me it was like my
norm
i just thought it's what i did um but i
still love responding to people
ad hoc and doing things and i i do think
what makes social media unique is the
conversation element
i do think that in the 070809 era it was
all hippie nirvana land it was all nice
it's not that anymore and i think that
leads to
people's different relationships with
social media
but but i get great enjoyment from
engaging with communities and
you know you learn things right i reply
nicely to one thing from you and
next thing i know i'm like what's money
twitter money twitter's in the building
right
like you know and like like seeing that
whole unearthed community and i always
love seeing you know for me
i'll always be attracted to the young
bucks
you know when i see that kind of energy
i'm like oh like i i have love for that
i'm like good for that like good for
people like
doing it like you know what i mean like
as an as
a mid aged lion now you know who was
always a young lion
you know i see a lot of mid-aged and old
lions get bitter about young lions
wanting to like [ __ ] on them and this
and that
i never understand i'm like you were
that young lion
you know um
it was funny i i just have always not
understood i
cheer for the youth i don't understand
how people don't
i also am competitive you know it was
funny some of the comments
in our exchange some people like gary's
to pass if he's not about making that
money i was laughing i was like let's do
a money off dick
wins like you know i'm doing brand while
people do
sales that's where people get confused
nike's not out here pedaling
but that swoosh is worth a zillion and i
think people
you know will evolve their thinking and
things that nature but
i also like the competitive spirit i
still am in the prime of my career so
getting down with the young lions
like i can grind it with the best of
them so
i'm about that life but i'm also about
having a well-rounded combo
because i don't think most people have
the self-esteem that i have and when
they're
dealt with adversity that's when they go
into sad places i also do think that
people
are flexing too much perception versus
reality i didn't have those issues
and i wanted i want to be responsible
with my platform to talk about all
angles because some people could be
about that money for a year and a half
but end up at zero i know those people
i know unlimited people that were about
that money life for two or three years
four years
so much so that they built an unstable
unsustainable model
and lost all the way from never being
financially sound again
all the way to the extremes of taking
their lives and i think
i think good balanced conversations
matter
and i i think that demonizing patience
makes me laugh
that's just confusion that doesn't mean
sit on your ass
you know one of the kids said something
in the thing and made me tweet i'm like
don't confuse patience with non-action
i'm out here burning it every day
but but you can't expect everything to
happen in two seconds
how did your grandmother's negativity
impact your own positivity because i
think this is a
an important point that you were able to
take that
negativity and and turn into positivity
what do you think the relationship there
is
it's huge she was a big part of my life
she was my only grandparent
you know and it's tough right she's
passed recently it's like tough to talk
about your only grandparent that you
knew
maybe in a negative light i don't my
grandma esther
had a very negative mother i knew her my
great grandmother and guess what
i have a funny feeling that my
great-grandmother had a very negative
mother or father i just didn't know them
so this is not to call out my
grandmother um but
you know i watched my grandma my
grandmother spent her entire summers
with us
you know and her negativity was very
very real and very against my religion
and
not how i saw the world and i saw the
effects of how
that affected my dad my dad has a lot of
variables that i know come from having a
negative mom and i also it was also
in the contrast of me having a positive
mom
and a supporting system so it was this
crazy contrast
and i also had my natural convictions so
by the time i was eight nine ten eleven
i was already like a weird dude i was in
in my zone in my bubble sounds like you
like if you were that young
into my stuff you were that's different
for 13 and i was that guy and so
she wasn't able to like her negativity
wasn't able to penetrate
me but it made me very empathetic i
think my opening answers here to
how do i deal with hate probably come
from the learnings of being
around someone who had negativity in
their dna
your life seems to me from an outside
perspective a tale of tools
two cities where you're able to use that
dichotomy i don't want to hold you for
too long gary
i'm going to go over by five minutes so
you got six more minutes because i'm
enjoying this because you're doing a
good job
asking different stuff and then i
appreciate that that means you're
putting in the work
of course and so when you yes
yes you made a very good point i'll
spend a second on it
my closeness to negativity cynicism
and positivity is a very huge framework
to my success
i both sides of my family had some
opposite dna traits on that front
and my ability to observe i'm a great
observer
you know and so you can imagine that was
my life so i observed it
and so i have compassion sympathy
empathy and understanding of both sides
i do not think being optimistic is
delusion
like i don't think when people keep it
real they keep it real i think they keep
it real cynical
you know like keeping it real is not
saying anything and just executing
you know when you're just [ __ ] on
everything you're not keeping it real
you're tearing down other buildings
eight out of ten times
sometimes you're keeping it real but
every friend i've had that's a big
i keep it real is actually cynical
and so you know absolutely
so final question when you love as many
people
as hard as you do with as much love
how do you deal with death death is
something that
is it seems like it's it's gonna happen
to us all so how do you deal with that
when you're loving more than the average
person when you're when you have that
how do you deal with death and and how
do you can you talk about that
i can but the way i'm going to talk
about it to be very interesting
my the closest person i've ever lost in
my life is my grandmother
and the reality and transparent truth is
it was probably the weakest relationship
i had in my inner circle
i lost three of my grandparents before i
knew them two before i was born
and my parents were in their 20s when
they like 20 when they had me
20 my mom was 20 my dad was 21 and a
half
so 22 just turned 22. so
the reality is uh another thing people
say to me sometimes like gary i don't
listen to you anymore you say the same
stuff i'm like mazel
i'm like good i'm like i want to talk
that's what you want
i want to talk about the stuff i know i
also believe
that one of the only reasons to kind of
stay on top of me is
i'm very good at observing the new
places
so if i'm listening to me i'd probably
be like after a while okay i get it oh
okay the reason i'm gonna check in with
this dude or kind of keep an eye on it
is because of the tick tock thing
and the snapchat like he's gonna be
right and that's gonna be good for me
and i'm gonna stay on that boat
and two seven nine times a year
that macro thing is good to get
reinforced no different than the reason
i call my best friend brandon or my mom
because sometimes i want a little
positive reinforcement and i go to them
so i'm thrilled that i am that for so
many people
um so the answer is i don't know
the answer to your question your final
question is i have no goddamn clue
because i would argue the majority of
people on this listening to this
have been through a death that hurt them
more than me
and they have more credibility to speak
to this subject than i do i can tell you
that there's an incredible amount of
fear that runs through my body
of losing one of those 10 15 closest
people to me in the world
because i do think i'm gonna really
struggle
or i'm gonna surprise myself and be very
grateful for like i'm a
very grateful optimistic dude it's gonna
be an interesting tug of war
of my devastation versus my gratitude
and until i live it i can't speak to it
with conviction the way i'd speak about
all the other things i speak about well
i really appreciate your time
don't want to take up any more of it
everything else you know this is going
to be it so i figured
you know three minutes late for my next
meeting anyways or anything else you
wanted to get in any
anything random when you started
wine library what were did you set a
goal of yourself for
i'm going to record x amount of episodes
did you
i'm gonna go and i know it's gonna be
successful yes and i know
let me tell you something else that
might help actually see this is what i
[ __ ] intuitively felt
it was good to get one more question
this is gonna help a ton of [ __ ]
youngsters
i think i knew that the learnings
from the process were going to be
valuable enough for the entire
commitment to time i knew that i was
going to do something
innovative i knew i was going to learn
something think about it i was doing
youtube
long form that was unheard of i was
using social media to promote it
that was super unheard of i knew that i
was going to get bigger into the tech
world
i was front facing camera personality
i'd never done that in my god damn life
i didn't i got a d in speech i didn't i
wasn't in drama
i was barely a class clown this is you
know so
i knew that i was going to learn a lot
about myself
and things that could help me
and then i did it as long as i wanted to
do it which ended up being five [ __ ]
years five days a week
you know in five years doing only a
monday through friday show no weekends
i did a thousand episodes think about
that that's like
insane levels of consistency um and so
i am proud of that and i did learn a lot
i mean it was foundational to my career
i think a lot of guys and girls
listening right now
overthink the roi of their actions in
their youth
and they don't realize the context and
the learning are going to be more
valuable than the financial
ramifications in that short window
that's exactly what i'm doing with this
podcast god bless you gary thank you for
your impact on my life
i appreciate you have a great one cheers
you brother bye-bye
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you